joining us now and I'm delighted he's
with us Doug shown Democratic pollster
former adviser to President Clinton Doug
um this is a truth I think the Democrats
don't want to hear about Joe Biden um
and it's coming out in these polls day
after day is there a possibility of a
plan B here given how dire this looks
yes I think there is Laura and plan B as
I conceive of it and I think it's
realistic is that Joe Biden in the face
of more discouraging polls meets with
his family over the holidays and uh
decides that for a variety of reasons
the polls his age his health um the
investigations into himself now and
Hunter Biden he decides not to run and
plan B and incredible as it may seem is
probably kamla
Harris wait I just I think I just my
heart just skipped to beat KLA Harris
okay yeah it might she's more unpopular
than he is I know Laura but this is the
Democratic party of 2024 and your
silence is entirely appropriate under
the circumstances we
face all right Doug we'll get back to
that I hope in a moment but I want to go
over some of the specifics on where
Trump is showing these significant gains
over Biden this is since October of 2020
Independence he's up 21% black voters
he's up uh 133% with Hispanic voters
black voters 15% and eight points with
Suburban voters a lot of those Suburban
women taking a second look at Trump so
that type of erosion and then you add in
the youth vote which again I I I kept
looking back saying this this has to be
false this can't be true I don't see how
AA Harris comes in and turns that around
she's just a younger version of the same
old bad policies that don't work I I
think that that is right and I think my
party would do well to look well beyond
KLA Harris but uh if at the 11th hour so
to speak Joe Biden steps down the filing
dates in a lot of states are passed the
black leadership in the Democratic party
which is responsible after role for the
nomination and indeed election of Joe
Biden I think we'll insist that KLA
Harris be the nominee and the process
will effectively be wired for her Gavin
Nome is the only one I think who would
have an outside chance of contesting the
nomination well and that's why he made
the trip to Beijing and he was there to
welcome G you know he's a man who who
has a firm fitting on the international
stage Etc but Janet Yellen was asked um
a very prominent Cabinet member of
course treasury secretary uh she also
went over to Beijing she was asked about
these numbers this is what she said
we're making considerable progress in
bringing inflation down but um Americans
do notice higher prices from what they
used to be accustomed to I think it's
our job to um explain to Americans what
President Biden has done to improve the
economy they keep thinking it's a
messaging problem Doug but the fact of
the matter is people are going to the
pumps and going to the grocery stores
and they can buy less with the dollars
that they're earning they can't change
that fact no no Janet yell and attempt
at you know redoing the message lamely
is going to change that it's not going
to change it I have said all along as
you are now saying Laura that to just
believe they can explain the inflation
reduction act which does nothing of the
sort uh is a Fool's errand it's not
going to work bottom line they need need
to change policies tighten uh the
southern border once and for all
acknowledge that problem cut spending
reduce the size of government take
meaningful steps to reduce the deficit
bottom line I don't think it's going to
happen uh in a any any chance it happens
uh in this election year but that's what
the American people want because the
Improvement you cited correctly is
because people are facing economic
stress with 20 25 30% higher prices due
to the Biden policies of spend spend
spend during the uh pandemic and as it
was winding
down and all too many Republican
Senators affirming that spending uh Doug
thank you so much great to have your
perspective tonight hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else